welcome to this video on Tony OB and
telling you be is to make an hour south
africa i'm sorry i actually know the
flag but i ah of course it's not to make
a fan that is stupid okay the king's
indian and let's see what line is going
from than our buck yep yeah night a six
or see fire those are the principal
choices let's see Queen d2 probably and
95 this is what what I had recently in a
game with white where for some reason
thought that before as possible which is
complete bogus iris playing playing the
other possible continuation with Queenie
eight gap is regrouping getting ready to
meet my f5 ok I'm going to play a five
yeah this is a possible way to play but
normally widest then going for long
castles I'm a bit surprised by short
castling okay one problem is the night
of course the night is not doing very
much night here I can play night before
and then a five let's do that I'm ever
have some doubts about this about this
operation but this this maybe gives me a
good square on c5
oks before FA for the way let's do that
I can block it I can block him queen is
only 8 95 yeah the problem might be the
queen when I have to have to do this
first I think yeah rookie one Queen only
a Jeff this is the thing that you don't
want to see how wow really ok that is
surprising at least for me whoa really
interesting very interesting
hmm yeah engage one why not um a form
must be something like that otherwise
I'm in trouble I mean maybe I'm in
trouble anyway so okay let's do that
it's slowly moved probably anyway that
that makes some sense at least for
getting active play and not just sitting
around yeah so I'm going to recapture
and if it takes with the bishop I really
don't know what to play bed queen age
for Bishop g3 push-up default check
kingi tune maybe this is really really
on whoa really so is going for what
exactly rook age one
I don't know I have to play move I don't
want to spend the whole whole time on
this decision
maybe between Air Force and it looks
completely bonkers but ok so he doesn't
mind that check that's it surprises me
check
threatening rookies have enough so
Bishop takes Bishop takes i'm in for
Bishop d3 check which is really annoying
this I didn't consider at all
look aged 50 g three SS any good
probably not yet I have no idea what's
going on here absolutely no idea if it
goes rook h form probably have to draw
it's certainly not the best option of
wine it looks like there should be some
kind of window wide time morning yeah I
don't I really have no idea how to win
here or try to win I mean as mentioned
the position is probably more mobile as
it's it's it's it's probably just worse
for me yeah I think you will try
something here we go okay check
hmm Jeff is this the great the great
thing that one had i dunno I have my
doubts
what is the the big the big move now the
big idea I don't see it I have some some
funny ideas myself like rook g5 and
stuff Roxy five Bishop g5 Queen Queen
age one check those kind of and trickery
came taking up stick first threatening
Bishop d3 check
to believe that there's no win I don't
see one
and i also see no move which is the
worst part check I've got seven seconds
him position is winning with seven
seconds
nice taking some time but seven seconds
is too much what we little whatever you
want to want to call it check Jenny
possibility is some kind of weird made
at black hats one time of course oh yeah
i was super complicated stuff where I
don't know what's going on really
probably we were both winning at some
point okay they are king f2 ever the
funny move but it's interesting so
around here might be three or strong
none didn't think at one yeah this is
just just the annual we're quite clearly
pizza
ah this is a maid actually I can jealous
you know what I totally forgot is that I
have this check here I totally forgot
the check this is very easier just just
made check just meeting him check
checkmate you said to mate with check
check check now i simply i simply forgot
that check the term the check with the
night is existing i was so so fixed on I
was just check not seeing it or I was
seeing that this is not working but I
didn't see that the nidus is there this
is stupid yeah I mean jack what I played
wins but of course you know the time and
so on yeah sir and why did that just
takes you 10 it's been a long day it's
been a very long day this I mean I have
slight chances if I takes you on him
this is I can do a ton of pre moves now
check like here here here maybe maybe
it's very difficult probably won't
manage but yeah there's was a really
really bad game but it's been a long
session ok well thanks for watching